salud en directo américa aquí en france
24 ya está conmigo en el estudio más
romeros a la mar bienvenida feliz inicio
de semana para ti hablemos de los 5
millones de muertos por kobe 19 el mundo
ya sobrepasó entonces esa cifra casi dos
años después del inicio de esta pandemia
más repreguntó que tanto ha cambiado
pues buenos días raúl como debes saber
muchísimas cosas han cambiado sin lugar
a dudas es una cifra para lamentar igual
que todo el número de contagios
acumulados pero estamos en una situación
muy diferente a la que estábamos cuando
empezó la pandemia en 2020 hay más
investigación hay una reapertura en
vacunas entonces pues para hablar de
todo esto para hacer un balance vamos a
hablar con el doctor carlos eduardo
pérez médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia cuando
podremos decir que la pandemia ha
terminado
en este momento estamos hablando de una
fase de desaceleración en las pandemias
se sabe cuándo inicia pero no se sabe
cuándo termina muy probablemente vamos a
pasar a otra fase que se llama la fase
endémica la fase endémica es donde se
van a presentar brotes en alguna parte
del mundo pero ya no va a ser un proceso
generalizado este proceso esa
desaceleración de los casos nos permite
prever que el final de esta fase
pandémica puede hacer el primer semestre
del siguiente año sin embargo tenemos
que estar alertas a las variantes al
proceso vacunación para que podamos
determinar un punto en donde se pase la
pandemia a la fase en técnica nada más
imaginó ese titular del fin de la
pandemia y me emociono pero hemos
hablado los errores que hemos cometido
durante la pandemia pero ahora cual él
cuáles son los aciertos autor
creo que son grandecitos que se han
hecho y que han sido grandes aciertos y
que van a quedar para el futuro
uno es el desarrollo rápido de vacunas
que fue una respuesta de la ciencia al
problema la segunda la sólida la
solidaridad entre los científicos muchos
grupos de trabajo se pusieron al unísono
para trabajar buscando una respuesta
kings lo tercero también fue muy
importante
entender y reconocer que el problema
medioambiental y el problema de
pandémico lo enfrentamos entre todos y
no segmentar ya mente y además de es un
gran aporte que hubo de la unión entre
los diferentes grupos académicos para
lograr respuestas medicamentos
anticuerpos monoclonales vacunas y todo
eso han sido buenas noticias de la
ciencia y seguramente después de la
pandemia vamos a tener desarrollo
científico mucho más grande claro hay un
avance muy significativo como estaba
diciendo que precisamente es esa rapidez
en desarrollar las vacunas que nos vamos
a llevar de eso para después de la
pandemia cuál ha sido el mayor logro de
esta carrera por las vacunas
es un avance sorprendente por dos
situaciones lo primero por haber hecho
una en una en una pandemia una vacuna en
un tiempo récord y lo segundo porque se
destacaron dos nuevas plataformas una
que se llama de adenovirus y mensajero
esto va a abrir un nuevo episodio en la
ciencia que es la vacunología porque ya
se están desarrollando vacunas de
acuerdo a este concepto para otras
enfermedades prevalentes infecciosas y
algunas no infecciosas y esto va a ser
seguramente las próximas décadas un gran
hito en la investigación porque el
desarrollo no solamente de la vacuna
para coronario si no haber probado las
plataformas su seguridad y su expansión
y su rapidez de preparación no se nos
advierte que viene un futuro muy
promisorio en la vacunología en el
siguiente tiempo
ahora doctor que sabemos de la
transmisión del coi 19 las personas que
están completamente vacunadas
las vacunas son buenas pero no perfectas
estas vacunas evitan la mortalidad pero
no evitan la cadena de transmisión eso
hace que el estar vacunado nos prevenga
de enfermarnos individualmente pero
colectivamente va a permitir un cap en
la transmisión una brecha en donde las
personas pueden transmitir sobre todo
eso lo hemos visto en la variante delta
es un proceso que se debe enfrentar con
nuevas vacunas y por ahora la vacuna que
disponemos es muy efectivo para el
control individual de la salud pero
todavía nos falta ese gran que es el
concepto colectivo de la inmunidad y
todo nuestro alto no avance hacia es
hacia esa hace ese convento entonces
doctor ya para terminar mirando hacia el
futuro ahí hay alguna posibilidad de
desarrollar tecnología próximamente que
nos permita no sólo prevenir el cóver
grave sino también las infecciones y los
contagios
si ya se están reformulando las vacunas
y se están haciendo vacunas que sean pan
genotípicas que cubran todas estas
variantes porque el escape de las
variantes a la vacuna inicial o a las
vacunas iniciales fue lo que no cortó la
cadena de transmisión se vienen
desarrollando y muy probablemente en el
próximo año ya tengamos una nueva
formulación de vacunas que prevengan esa
cadena de transmisión y ahí sí ya será
un paso hacia la inmunidad colectiva
pero la suma de medicamentos efectivos
que hemos visto recientemente
anticuerpos monoclonales
preventivos por exposición y post
exposición sumado a las vacunas que
tenemos disponible si sumamos todo esto
tenemos un gran avance para finalizar la
fase pandémica y entrar en la fase
endémica muchas gracias doctor como cada
lunes por estar con nosotros
definitivamente hay motivos para
alegrarnos raúl no todos son malas
noticias y al final de las cosas malas
también salen cosas buenas como todo
este avance en la investigación que
estamos cubriendo aquí en salud con las
cosas malas aprendemos más muchísimas
gracias a ti y al doctor por esta
información de salud hoy cuando
lamentablemente también el mundo que
pasan estos 5 millones de fallecidos por
la pandemia oficialmente reconocidos más
gracias